un soutien de poids pour aurore bergé
dans la course à la députation la
candidate de la république en marche la
10e circonscription rencontrer ce
mercredi nicolas hulot l'actuel ministre
d'état de la transition écologique a
visité avec la femme politique les
étangs de hollande construit sous louis
xiv on est au coeur d'une
circonscription rurale encore d'une
circonscription la biodiversité la
protection de l'environnement la
protection de la nature se doivent être
au coeur de nos priorités des étangs que
l'ancien présentateur de télévision et
ambassadeurs de l'environnement connais
bien le ministre a vécu à saint léger en
yvelines pendant une dizaine d'années il
ya derrière ça aussi un message c'est
qu'il ya l'aspect récréatif régénérant
des forêts mais notre sort est lié à la
protection et la réhabilitation des
écosystèmes donc à mes futurs aux futurs
députés j'espère pouvoir faire ce
plaidoyer en direct comme je vais le
faire le gouvernement aujourd'hui dans
le gouvernement de la république en
marche nicolas hulot n'a pas apporté son
soutien au candidat écologiste sur la
circonscription david jutier un choix
qu'il assume et paradoxes sont nombreux
mais ce qu'on voit bien on sait qu'il ya
un rabattage des cartes
alors ça vous en france dans le monde
voyez bien quand même que tout toutes
les alliances habituel
encore une fois moi je ne suis pas là
pour faire une campagne contre les uns
et les autres après avoir vraiment
besoin de tout le monde précède aux
électeurs de choisir le week-end
prochain en fonction de leur sensibilité
dans la 10e circonscription des yvelines
aurore bergé sera l'une des favorites
pour le poste de député la candidate de
30 ans devra notamment batailler face au
député sortant jean-frédéric poisson du
parti chrétien démocrate